families for our Fortress families are  fortunate and you see it that's what the  movie he says in the movie and that's  what I'm always telling my wife my wife  I'm out ex-wife sorry I'm always telling  her Deborah I'm like well Joshua right  right it comes into the picture he okay  so the thing about Joshua is Joshua can  take them to see Thor he can take them  to see wakanda forever I don't care you  know but this is my franchise this is  I've I love Avatar I've loved it since  it came out and so and I love the  rolling reset where you just keep going  and keep going and keep going I'm  getting to a point I don't mean you know  in advance what your intention is that's  how you form the the sentence right it's  Joshua right Joshua is there he he took  the kids to see Avatar Two I had to see  it alone it was no matter what you can  take what you go through in terms of  dysfunction I feel families your  Fortress I feel the exact same way